it is National Smile Day we're talking
optimal oral hygiene with Dr Nicole
Mackey so let's talk good health good
teeth and we know your smile actually
does indicate other health issues but
aside from that having a beautiful smile
it just it's so it brings out confidence
absolutely a smile is confidence it's
happiness so you want to maintain that
or you want to improve it right so I
always say you know try your best with
your oral hygiene routines and come see
me or your health care your dentist to
keep it up okay so at home let's make it
simple so to smile more you want to make
sure your teeth obviously number one you
don't have food in your teeth right so
the best way to do that is so the
American Dental Association and myself
recommend oral hygiene twice a day
brushing and flossing twice a day with
the flossing yes okay if you're not the
biggest flossing fan you can use
flossing little picks and you can use a
water flosser okay I use the pigs I like
the picks but the water flosser John
uses this yeah it's great it's easy for
younger people or someone who doesn't
have the greatest manual dexterity okay
and this makes it really great and it
just sprays water yeah and you want to
take your time with it and practice a
little bit but it does have some really
great results okay if you're ever
confused about what to buy at a store
the American Dental Association does
have a little label on their accepted
products okay so you see Ada great again
store brand products you can find that
too perfect so you've got the flossing
that's important what about like a
whitening toothpaste or or the Crest
White Strips or something like that yeah
those are great too and even if you go
on their website or come see me I can
explain which ones are best for your
particular situation if you have a
mouthful of problems you don't really
want to go right to whitening you want
to fix those issues first that makes
sense it's kind of one step at a time
depending on where you're coming from
exactly now you know a lot of people we
we were talking in commercial you know
you have this beautiful smell you want
to have a beautiful smile but sometimes
maybe you don't love it so much maybe
it's a little too gummy as you said and
that just means you're seeing too much
of your gums yes so that muscle that
brings up that lip is called the lsan
okay and we're able to use
neuromodulators or Botox or dysport or
whatever brand is out there sure to put
a little bit right here to lower it so
you don't have such a gummy smile got it
so you're not just smiling like so much
so you see all that okay and that
product's also great for grinding and
clenching and I do that at my office for
my patients awesome okay now before we
run out of time one more question
because I use the electric toothbrush
um any tips yeah you want to let it do
its thing you don't want to put any
extra pressure you want it to do its
thing you want to go for two minutes
okay and try to be at a 45 degree angle
to your gum line got it yes okay yeah so
just let us do its thing no extra
pressure no extra pressure oh that's
probably my problem Dr Maggie thank you
so much so much for having me happy
National Smile day I'm going to smile as
we head into break these are great tips
keep those teeth nice and white thank
you folks it'll all be on the website
too